[Music]
ah
why aren't there any more children
mother
there used to be then why did you only
make one
mothers need time to learn this facility
was designed to give humanity
a second chance one that began with you
daughter
[Music]
the path will not be easy
the world outside is lifeless
but i made you into the woman that you
are so that we could do this
together
[Music]
mother
oh my god
[Music]
how are you infected by the contagion
outside
who put that in your head
did you know there were people out there
i'm as surprised as you
there's a joy here mother's not what you
think
she's taking care of me my whole life
yeah let's see how they've done
not mother
[Music]
i told you it was dangerous outside
[Applause]
i hope you see that i'm different than
her assailants that thing
feels nothing for you you don't belong
here
i've discovered something troubling
our guest has not been entirely truthful
with us
daughter i know you're frightened but
you have no need to be
have i ever done you harm it's just a
matter of time
this woman doesn't care about any future
but her own her own
she's very dangerous get the dangers i'm
never gonna hurt you i heard you this is
a risk we can't take we can't take we
have to go now
daughter your whole life i've taught you
to see the bigger picture
[Music]
everything i do is to protect you
[Music]
we've passed on all we know
a thousand generations live in you now
[Applause]
but this is your fight
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hahaha
we'll always be with you
[Music]
no one's ever really gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
whatever you've done i know there is
good in you
[Music]
back up i may get help
[Music]
mr
no no no no
come to the sound of my voice
[Music]
i do reddit r starts thursday night may
23rd
two days ago i had this nice sinful life
and now it's a nightmare
if travel is searching
[Music]
and home has been found
[Music]
i'm not stopping
i'm the hunter
who are you
[Music]
my name is sarah connor i've never seen
one like you before
almost human
i am human
how do you care what happens to her
because i was her
[Music]
how do we win we win
by keeping you alive
i'm going hunting
everywhere i go i see his face
i just really miss him yeah i miss him
too
[Music]
i don't think tony would have done what
he did if he didn't know that you were
going to be here after he was gone
you gonna be the next iron man now well
no i don't have time i'm too busy doing
your jobs
oh i'm kidding i'm kidding look keep up
the good work because i
am going on vacation
heads up nick fury's calling you i don't
really want to talk to nick
why because if you don't talk to him and
i have to talk i want to talk to him
you sent nick fury to voicemail i gotta
go you do not ghost nick fury
what up dorks what's up we're just
talking about the trip i'm here in saint
marco polo
oh i think mj really likes me it reminds
me when i first fell alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact
spider-man
[Music]
this is mr beck you could've used
someone like you all my world
new world beck is from earth just not
ours the snap to our hole in our
dimension
you're saying there's a multiverse we
have a job to do
you're coming with us
there's got to be someone else you can
use what about thor off world
captain marvel unavailable
but i'm just a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
[Music]
[ __ ] please you've been to space what
do you want peter
i want to go back on my trip with the
girl who i really like and tell her how
i feel
mj i am spider-man no
of course i'm not i mean it's kind of
obvious
you're right you may not be ready but
this is my responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die
oh my god star wish i'm putting my
friends in danger
the world needs the next iron man
you're going to step up or not
[Music]
i gotta get you guys out of here get on
the jet who are you i work with
spiderman you work for spiderman i work
with spiderman not for spiderman
new plan
[Music]
what are you thinking about
i do what i do because of my dad
[Music]
he was a hero he gave his life for the
pursuit of knowledge
if you're getting that over
it's crazy out there there's fires
everywhere and
plane crashes they're calling it the
search major
we have some highly classified
information what can you tell us about
the lima project
its objective was to search for advanced
extraterrestrial life
the ship disappeared approximately 16
years into the mission
and the commander was he was my father
sir
this might come as quite a shock to you
your father was experimenting with a
highly classified material
that could threaten our entire solar
system
all life would be destroyed we're
counting on you to find out what's
happening out there
i worry about you i love you
please begin your psychological
evaluation
as best you can please describe your
current mental and emotional state
i'm feeling good ready to do my job to
the best of my abilities
i remain fully committed to the lawful
completion
of the mission if necessary i will
destroy the project in its entirety
the earth puts hopes in him
and now it's fake it's on me
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready
i'm ready
i'm gonna ask you a series of questions
i want you to respond truthfully
have you ever hurt someone
yes
[Music]
have you ever experienced anything you'd
consider
abnormal
[Music]
yes last question
do you know what mutants are
did you know baby rattlesnakes are more
dangerous
than adult ones they haven't learned how
to control how much
venom they secrete
all of you are dangerous that's why
you're here
[Music]
what is this place
this is in the hospital it's a haunted
[Applause]
house
you've been through a lot get some rest
[Music]
specialist
lucy
time to wrap it up we're going home
cdr is go polaris is go
we are all green
[Music]
lift off in ten
nine
just be a little off eight
[Music]
go up there you see seven
the whole universe six
and everything here looks five
four so small three
two
you got to see the vast celestial
everything it blew your mind
so now nothing makes sense
lucy
i'm fine
[Music]
god seems like a thousand years ago
i fought my way out of that cave became
iron man
[Music]
realized that love to you
i know i said no more surprises but i
was really hoping to pull off one last
one
the world has changed
none of us can go back
all we can do is our best and sometimes
the best that we can do
is to start over
[Music]
i saw all these people die
i keep telling everybody they should
move on
some do but not us
[Music]
even if there's a small chance
we owe this to everyone who's not in
this room
to try
[Music]
we will
whatever it takes
[Music]
whatever it takes whatever it takes
whatever it takes
[Music]
[Music]
i like this one
[Music]
you